Marti was 22, just out of college, working as a waitress, living in LA, with vague ideas of getting into the film business, but no idea of how to do that, when a customer hooked her up with a job in the movie business, on the kind of fringes of the movie business actually, at a product placement company. These are the people who help companies get their name brand products into Hollywood films.
玛蒂当时22岁，刚大学毕业，做着服务员的工作，住在洛杉矶，对进入电影行业有着模糊的想法，但完全不知道该怎么做。这时，一位顾客给她介绍了一份电影行业的工作，确切地说是处于电影行业边缘地带的工作：一家植入式广告公司。这些人专门帮助品牌公司将产品植入好莱坞电影中。
And this was a job I didn't even know existed. But our big client was Budweiser. And I think one of the reasons I was really impressed with this job was that they took me to the breakroom, and they had a giant refrigerator shaped like a Budweiser can. And I just thought that was the coolest thing I'd ever seen.
这份工作我甚至都不知道它的存在。我们的大客户是百威啤酒。我想我之所以对这份工作印象深刻，原因之一是他们带我去了休息室，那里有一个巨大的百威啤酒罐形状的冰箱。我当时觉得那是我见过最酷的东西。
You were 22.
你当时22岁。
I was 22. It was full of beer.
我22岁。里面装满了啤酒。
It was the kind of job where you could drink as much beer as you wanted on the job. It was the kind of job where somebody regularly injected fish oil, which stank, into the upholstered chair of a boss that everybody hated. Marti had never actually worked in an office before, and she just thought, well, I guess this is what all office jobs are like. And she got to read scripts of movies before they were made, which was exciting, to look for places where characters could be drinking Budweiser or using other clients' products. And things went along like that for a while. And one day, the office manager tells Marti to wear a dress the next day and show up on time because auditors from Budweiser were going to be coming to the office.
那是一份可以在工作中随心所欲喝啤酒的工作。在那份工作中，经常有人往大家讨厌的老板的软垫椅子里注射臭气熏天的鱼油。玛蒂之前从没在办公室工作过，她以为所有的办公室工作都是这样。她还能在电影开拍前读到剧本，这让她很兴奋，因为可以寻找角色可以喝百威啤酒或使用其他客户产品的地方。事情就这样持续了一段时间。有一天，办公室经理让玛蒂第二天穿裙子准时上班，因为百威啤酒的审计人员要来办公室。
And I showed up the next morning, and there's this guy in a suit sitting in my office at my desk. I think he introduced himself. And he said, I'm going to pretend to be your boss today. And you're my secretary.
第二天早上我到了公司，有个穿西装的男人坐在我的办公室里，坐在我的办公桌前。我想他做了自我介绍。他说，我今天得假装是你老板。而你是我的秘书。
I guess at that point it was explained to me that my boss-- the big boss, the guy I never saw-- had been cooking the books and that, according to the books, there were 15 more employees over in our office than there actually were. So somebody's solution to this was to hire a bunch of actors to come in and play the employees who were supposed to be working there, including the person who was supposed to be running the quote unquote, "script department," who was someone who was not me, who was paid a whole lot more than me.
我想在那时我才明白，我的老板——那位我从未见过的大老板——一直在做假账。根据账面显示，我们办公室比实际人数多了15名员工。于是某人的解决方案就是雇佣一群演员来扮演那些本该在这里工作的员工，包括那个本该负责所谓的“剧本部门”的人，那个人不是我，而且他的薪水比我高得多。
In fact, Marti was told, she was doing, for $200 a week and still keeping her waitressing job, the work of three people, an entire department, that her company was actually billing Anheuser-Busch for. And, 22 years old, Marti never thought, OK, that's it, I'm walking. In fact, she was all, let's go, best day of work ever.
事实上，玛蒂被告知，她每周拿着200美元的薪水，还得兼职做服务员，却干着三个人的活，承担着整个部门的职责，而她的公司却实际上在向安海斯-布希公司（Anheuser-Busch）收取这些费用。22岁的玛蒂从来没想过“好吧，就这样了，我走人”。事实上，她当时想的是，来吧，这是有史以来最棒的工作日。
Now we're comrades. We're in on a scheme together. So I'm like, hey, I'm Marti. And he introduced himself. And I believe his name was Gary. And Gary was like, yeah, usually my gig is I'm a regular extra on All My Children. And I was really impressed. I just thought, wow, this guy is on TV. And he's all, so tell me how things really work here, and what should I say when they come in, and how does this computer work? And it was like we were getting ready to do a little play.
现在我们是同志了。我们是一伙的。所以我说，嘿，我是玛蒂。他也做了自我介绍。我相信他叫加里。加里说，是的，通常我的工作是做《我的孩子们》（All My Children）里的临时演员。我印象非常深刻。我当时想，哇，这家伙上过电视。他接着说，跟我说说这里到底是怎么运作的，他们进来时我该说什么，这台电脑怎么用？感觉我们就像在准备演一出小短剧。
Did it seem like it might work to you?
你觉得这能行吗？
Yeah. Oh yeah, definitely. Well, they were actors. They were a day player on Days of Our Lives. It was really impressive to me. I couldn't believe they'd hired the caliber of performers. I thought, wow, I can't believe they got people-- There were a bunch, one of whom was the cue card guy usually for Wheel of Fortune.
能。哦，绝对能。嗯，他们是演员。他们是《我们的日子》（Days of Our Lives）里的日播演员。这让我印象非常深刻。我不敢相信他们雇佣了这种级别的表演者。我想，哇，不敢相信他们竟然能找来这些人——还有一群人，其中有一个人平时是《幸运轮》（Wheel of Fortune）的提示卡工作人员。
They were on real shows.
他们上过真正的节目。
They were on real shows. They were on television, and they were here in our offices.
他们上过真正的节目。他们上过电视，而现在他们就在我们的办公室里。
And then the office manager gives the word, the auditors have arrived.
然后办公室经理发出信号，审计人员到了。
So yeah, she's all, they're here, they're here. And everybody started looking efficient.
所以，是的，她喊道，他们来了，他们来了。每个人都开始装作很忙的样子。
And at that point, people start bustling around, boxes are being carried from place to place.
在那一刻，人们开始忙碌起来，箱子被从一个地方搬到另一个地方。
Yeah, in my mind, it was like we're busy, happy employees. And everybody got busy because they were all those guys in the stockroom. And Gary is typing. God knows what he was typing. We're trying to look busy. And I remember they walked past us first. And your heart kind of skips, like, oh, they're coming to see us. And so all of a sudden, there's like four or five people standing around the door of this little office--
是的，在我的脑海里，感觉就像我们是忙碌、快乐的员工。大家都忙开了，因为他们都是储藏室里的那些家伙。加里在打字。天知道他在打什么。我们都在努力表现得很忙。我记得他们首先从我们身边走过。你的心跳会漏掉一拍，心想，哦，他们要来看我们了。突然，有四五个人站在这个小办公室的门口——
These are the people from Anheuser-Busch.
这些人是来自安海斯-布希公司的。
--kind of looking at us like we were an exhibit, the story department exhibit. And the guy who was pretending to be my boss was telling them about our projects. But he kept stopping because he'd sort of forget. And I would, of course, couldn't help myself. I'd start jumping in and going, bu-- ah-- ge-- and no, that's a Spike Lee project and stuff like that.
——他们看着我们，就像看着一个展览，那个故事部门的展览。那个假装是我老板的人正在向他们介绍我们的项目。但他一直在停顿，因为他有点忘了。我当然忍不住了，开始插嘴说，呃……啊……那个……那是斯派克·李（Spike Lee）的项目，之类的。
And I remember he was talking and fumbling his way through some explanation and looking at all these guys-- there was probably two or three men and this one woman-- and this one woman was looking at me. We kind of locked eyes. And I knew that she knew. It was this look like, I'm very disappointed in you. This is pitiful. And yeah.
我记得他当时一边说话一边笨拙地解释，看着这些人——大概有两三个男人和一个女人。那个女人正看着我。我们对视了。我知道她看穿了。她的眼神仿佛在说，我很失望。这太可怜了。是的。
The auditors left without saying anything at all. But within weeks, the company was coming apart. Paychecks were bouncing.
审计人员什么也没说就离开了。但在几周内，公司就开始分崩离析。支票开始跳票。
But what's so crazy about the whole scheme is that it's the sort of thing that somebody would do in a sitcom. Do you know what I mean? Oh, I know what we'll do. We'll hire actors to pretend to be the office workers.
但整个骗局最疯狂的地方在于，这简直是情景喜剧里才会发生的事。你明白我的意思吗？噢，我知道该怎么做了。我们雇些演员来假装是办公室职员。
No, it was like somebody had seen The Sting and thought, genius, I've got the plan. I'm surprised that they didn't just wheel the walls away of the whole place afterwards because it was just like that. It was a con.
不，这就像有人看过《骗中骗》（The Sting）然后心想，天才，我有计划了。我很惊讶他们事后没有把整个房子的墙都拆掉，因为它就像那样。这是一场骗局。
Which brings me to today's radio program about people doing some pretty extreme things to make money and some less extreme things to spend money. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today, a program about getting and spending and the things that people will do, as in Marti's story, because they feel they have no choice.
这让我引出了今天的广播节目，关于人们为了赚钱做的一些极端事情，以及为了花钱做的一些不那么极端的事情。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是公共广播国际（PRI）发行的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天，是一档关于获取和支出的节目，以及人们会做的事情，就像玛蒂的故事一样，因为他们觉得别无选择。
Act One of today's show, Mothers of Invention. In that act, Alex Kotlowitz and a half dozen people on how they felt they had to act to survive. Act Two, That Guy. In that act, we hear part of the psychology of spending money that is rarely discussed. Act Three, Mall Rat. John Hodgman and the alleged secret tunnels under the Mall of America. Stay with us.
今天节目的第一幕，“发明之母”。在这一幕中，亚历克斯·科特洛维茨（Alex Kotlowitz）和六个人讲述了他们为了生存不得不采取的行动。第二幕，“那个人”。在那一幕中，我们将听到关于花钱心理的一部分，这一点很少被讨论。第三幕，“商场老鼠”。约翰·霍奇曼（John Hodgman）讲述美国购物中心地下的所谓秘密隧道。请留下来。
And let's begin with Act One. Alex Kotlowitz has found that lately when he's been talking to people about money, what everybody seems to be coming back to is how money changed them, and how they feel ashamed of that. And how they feel all sorts of other feelings that they aren't so proud of. Here's Alex.
让我们从第一幕开始。亚历克斯·科特洛维茨发现，最近当他和人们谈论金钱时，每个人似乎都在反复强调金钱是如何改变他们的，以及他们对此感到多么羞耻。还有他们感受到的所有其他并不引以为傲的情绪。下面有请亚历克斯。
Not long ago, I got taken for $250. I know it's not a huge amount of money, but it's embarrassing. We all like to think we're too savvy to be had. But here's why I really hesitate to share this story. I was had by a minister, a man of God.
不久前，我被骗了250美元。我知道这不是一笔巨款，但很丢人。我们都喜欢认为自己太精明了，不会被骗。但我真正犹豫要不要分享这个故事的原因是：我被一位牧师骗了，一个上帝的仆人。
This pastor has a storefront church on Chicago's South Side, and he kept some of the money I'd given him to help bail a mutual friend out of jail. I don't know that he planned it. He was clearly struggling financially. He'd been a terrific mentor to my young friend, helping him through some tough times. But the opportunity presented itself, and too often, money gets in the way of even our best intentions. It exposes us.
这位牧师在芝加哥南区有一家店面教堂，他扣留了我给他的一部分钱，那是为了帮一位共同的朋友交保释金。我不知道他是不是预谋的。他显然在经济上很拮据。他曾是我年轻朋友的一位了不起的导师，帮他度过了一些艰难时刻。但机会摆在了面前，金钱往往会阻碍我们最好的意图。它暴露了我们。
I've been talking to a lot of people lately who thought money exposed them. Like my friend Marty Oberman. He was a Chicago Alderman for 12 years, and he got into politics out of a 1960s idealism. He'd been involved in the anti-war movement, and he earned a reputation as a reformer, as an opponent of the city's political machine. But slowly, almost imperceptibly, money began to change him starting when he first took office.
最近我一直在和很多人交谈，他们认为金钱暴露了他们。比如我的朋友马蒂·奥伯曼（Marty Oberman）。他当了12年的芝加哥市议员，出于60年代的理想主义进入政界。他曾参与反战运动，并以改革者的身份，作为城市政治机器的反对者而赢得了声誉。但慢慢地，几乎难以察觉地，金钱开始改变他，从他第一次上任时就开始了。
Two or three weeks after I was elected in 1975, a neighbor of mine-- I was out walking my dog, and he came up to me. And he was a good friend and supporter. And he said, boy, you have really offended so and so. And I was stunned. I didn't know what he was talking-- I said, what are you talking about?
1975年我当选两三周后，我的一位邻居——我当时正在遛狗，他走过来。他是一位好朋友和支持者。他说，天哪，你真的冒犯了某某某。我惊呆了。我不知道他在说什么——我说，你在说什么？
He said, two days ago, you walked right past this guy on LaSalle Street and didn't say hello, didn't even acknowledge him. And he gave you $100. I didn't know what he was talking about. I'm sure I did walk past him on LaSalle Street. I was probably in a conversation or in thought. And this friend of mine really chewed me out.
他说，两天前，你在拉萨尔街（LaSalle Street）直接从那家伙身边走过，没打招呼，甚至没理他。他可是给了你100美元的。我不知道他在说什么。我肯定在拉萨尔街走过他身边。我可能当时在交谈或者在思考。我的这位朋友真的把我痛骂了一顿。
Well, that doesn't have to happen too many times before you reflexively start smiling and shaking hands and sounding phony to everybody you meet. You don't know if they gave you money, if they're going to give you money. You become a glad-hander, but you don't have a choice. This is what it does to you.
嗯，这种事只要发生几次，你就会不由自主地开始微笑、握手，对你遇到的每个人表现得虚伪。你不知道他们是否给了你钱，或者他们将来会不会给你钱。你成了那种逢人就打招呼的人，但你别无选择。这就是它对你做的事情。
One time, a real estate developer had $1,000 check delivered to Marty. The developer needed a favor. The check sat in Marty's desk for a month before he finally decided to tear it up. He eventually ran for statewide office and had to ask people for contributions of $10,000 and $15,000. He always feared what favors they'd be asking in return. Then one day, he found himself asking someone for $50,000.
有一次，一位房地产开发商给马蒂送去了一张1000美元的支票。开发商需要一个帮忙。支票在马蒂的桌子上放了一个月，他最后才决定把它撕了。他最终竞选州公职，不得不向人们索要1万美元和1.5万美元的捐款。他总是担心他们会要求什么样的回报。后来有一天，他发现自己正在向别人索要5万美元。
Why would a person write a check like that? One had to assume that he didn't give the $50,000 not thinking that someday, he might want to ask for something. And I knew then that I did not want to be doing this.
一个人为什么要写那种支票？你不得不认为，他给那5万美元时，并不是没想到有一天他可能想要求回报。那一刻我知道，我不想再做这种事了。
Marty told me he thought he could be a politician unaffected by money, that he could do it differently. But instead, he got out of politics.
马蒂告诉我，他以为自己能成为一个不受金钱影响的政客，以为他能以不同的方式做事。但相反，他退出了政界。
Ted Fishman thought he could do it differently too. For nine years, back in the 1980s, Ted, now an accomplished journalist, was a trader in the Chicago Mercantile Exchange. There, money is everything. But Ted figured he'd always be able to keep his perspective.
泰德·费什曼（Ted Fishman）也以为他能以不同的方式行事。在80年代，作为一名杰出的记者，泰德曾是芝加哥商品交易所（Mercantile Exchange）的交易员，长达九年。在那里，金钱就是一切。但泰德认为他总能保持自己的视角。
I remember just before I traded for the very first time, I had a meeting with the head of my clearing company, which is the organization on an exchange that acts sort of like your bank and does a lot of your bookkeeping for you. And this was an experienced trader, a pretty glamorous guy. He had a big shock of hair and was always wearing Italian suits.
我记得在第一次交易前，我和我的结算公司负责人开过一个会，那是交易所内相当于你的银行并为你处理大量记账工作的机构。那是一位经验丰富的交易员，一个相当迷人的家伙。他有一头浓密的头发，总是穿着意大利西装。
And he invited all the new traders in who were going to use his clearing corp, and he gave us a little talk. And his message to us was that we should fight for every single dollar. Don't give anything up. Out on the street, he said, people kill for $5. You should act like every $5 means something to you. And I was duly charged.
他邀请了所有使用他们结算公司的交易员参加，给我们做了一个简短的讲座。他传达给我们的信息是，我们应该为每一美元而战。什么都不要放弃。他说，在外面，人们会为了5美元杀人。你应该表现得好像每一美元对你来说都有意义一样。我被妥妥地激励了。
My first day on the Merc was humbling to say the least. People who hear my voice know that I have kind of a high voice, kind of a Topo Gigio type voice. And it can be really grating. Well, when I screamed in the pits for the first time, the other traders around actually held their ears. And because I was trained to just keep announcing prices of this and that, and where I would buy, and where I would sell-- I'll pay 100 on 12, 30 at 1,000, I'll pay 12 on 100. Then you'd have to check it. You'd say, I'm checking, 12 on 100, 12 on 100.
我在商业交易所的第一天简直是让人谦卑。听过我声音的人都知道我的嗓音比较高，有点像Topo Gigio那种嗓音。而且真的很刺耳。嗯，当我第一次在交易池里大喊时，周围的其他交易员竟然捂住了耳朵。因为我被训练得只会不断报出这样那样的价格，以及我的买入价和卖出价——“我出100买12，1000出30，我出12买100”。然后你得确认。你会说，“我在确认，12买100，12买100。”
And so here I was with my loud, screaming voice. And a guy came up to me, and he said, why don't we just write you a check, and you can shut up and go home. And then actually, a guy who I had befriended on the exchange came up and made the first trade with me. And it was kind of my initiation. The hazing was done, and I made that first trade.
所以我就在这里用我那高分贝尖叫的声音。一个人走到我面前说，我们干脆给你开张支票，你闭嘴回家吧。然后，一个我在交易所结识的朋友走过来，和我完成了第一笔交易。这算是我的入行仪式吧。欺凌结束了，我完成了那第一笔交易。
Once I made the commitment to trade, I had the most grandiose visions of my future. I would be one of the rich guys with a big mansion. I would earn enough money to run my own philanthropy because I was a do-gooder. And I made a lot of money. I made more money than I knew what it was really. I would go to Neiman Marcus and buy two Armani suits after a good day and fantasize about all the other things downtown that I would buy. And I did pretty well for a while.
一旦我下定决心做交易，我对自己的未来就有了最宏伟的愿景。我会成为拥有大豪宅的富人之一。我会赚到足够的钱来经营自己的慈善事业，因为我是个好人。我确实赚了很多钱。我赚的钱多到我不知道该怎么办。日子好过的时候，我会去尼曼马库斯（Neiman Marcus）买两套阿玛尼西装，幻想市中心其他我想买的东西。有一段时间我确实做得不错。
One thing that happened that was very sobering for me was waking up one morning to the news on the radio. And the news that morning in April 1986 was that there had been a terrible nuclear disaster in the Soviet Union. And this was the Chernobyl disaster. And I just heard about this irradiated cloud that was floating over Europe, and I didn't want to get myself to work. The news was too sad.
发生的一件事让我非常清醒，那就是一天早上醒来听到电台的新闻。1986年4月的那天早上，新闻报道说苏联发生了一场可怕的核灾难。那就是切尔诺贝利灾难。我听说了那朵飘过欧洲的辐射云，我不想去上班。新闻太悲伤了。
But when I did get to work, I noticed that there was more energy on the floor than usual. And I thought, well, what's going on here? Is there something I don't know? What was going on was that the whole exchange was giddy over the prospects of this nuclear disaster. And I was in the cattle pit at the time. And one of the first things somebody said to me was, well, all the pigs in Denmark are going to be dead. So the cattle price went sky high.
但当我到了公司，我注意到交易大厅里的能量比平时高。我想，怎么回事？有什么我不知道的事吗？发生了什么事是，整个交易所都在为这场核灾难的前景而感到眩晕。我当时在牲畜交易池。别人跟我说的第一件事就是，好吧，丹麦的猪都要死光了。所以牛的价格飞涨。
And that's when I learned the dictum that disasters are good for commodity trading. As soon as I got in the action, all of that sadness disappeared. And I just jumped into the game. And that disaster made me more money in one day than I had made in my entire life up to then.
也就是在那时，我学到了那句格言：灾难对商品交易是好消息。一旦我投入到行动中，所有的悲伤都消失了。我直接跳进了游戏。那场灾难让我一天赚的钱比我之前一辈子赚的还多。
It was like you show up every day to work hoping that everyone in your pit dies, and you get all their money. At the exchange, you create these castles of rationalization for your job. You've come to think, along with everybody else in those pits, that you're doing something essential to the operation of the world. But the truth, of course, in the end is it's all about money.
就像你每天上班都希望交易池里的每个人都死掉，然后你拿走他们所有的钱。在交易所，你为你的工作创造了这些合理的堡垒。你开始和交易池里的其他人一样认为，你在为世界的运行做着必不可少的事情。但真相，当然，归根结底全是关于金钱。
Several years after I quit trading, of course, the United States was attacked by terrorists in 9/11. And the exchanges in the nation were closed. But my brother was still trading on the CBOE at that time, Chicago Board Options Exchange. And I went back with him to help him out on the day that the exchange opened for the first day. And there again, I saw the very same giddiness that existed after the Chernobyl disaster. Here we were with the worst domestic attack in the United States history, and the traders were running around as happy as could be. And they would stop each other in the hall saying, you know, I don't feel good for what happened, but I'm doing great. You hate to be doing great, but I'm doing great. And they may be doing great, but I was pretty glad that I wasn't doing great that day.
我停止交易几年后，美国当然遭遇了9/11恐怖袭击。全国的交易所都关闭了。但在那个时候，我弟弟还在芝加哥期权交易所（CBOE）交易。交易所重新开张的第一天，我回去帮他。在那里，我又看到了切尔诺贝利灾难后那种同样的眩晕感。这里我们面对的是美国历史上最严重的国内袭击，而交易员们却跑来跑去，开心得不得了。他们在走廊里拦住彼此说，你知道，我对发生的事情感到难过，但我现在赚得盆满钵满。你不想在这个时候大赚特赚，但我确实赚疯了。他们可能赚得很爽，但我很高兴那天我没赚得那么爽。
The bottom had fallen out of everything in my life. So I'm thinking, well, where can I walk in where there's a cash register, where they have a couple hundred bucks so I can make my car payment?
我生活中的一切都彻底破灭了。所以我心想，哪里有收银机，哪里有几百块钱，好让我能付车贷？
Bill Thompson was desperate. Like Ted Fishman, he had traded commodities. And though he wasn't as successful, he made a pretty good living at it. He bought a home in Winnetka, a tony suburb north of Chicago. And when he was in his mid-30s, he married for a second time and had a son. Things were going pretty well.
比尔·汤普森（Bill Thompson）绝望了。像泰德·费什曼一样，他也交易过商品。虽然他没那么成功，但也赚得不错。他在芝加哥以北一个高档郊区温内特卡（Winnetka）买了一套房子。他在30多岁时第二次结婚，并生了一个儿子。一切都很顺利。
But then he lost his job, and he didn't bounce back. He tried all sorts of things to make ends meet. He sold home security systems. He put up a 976 line for a guy, so he could talk to girls on the phone. He worked sales jobs on the phone, earning $8 an hour. He half-jokingly would say he was part of the working poor, but still living in Winnetka.
但他失业了，没能东山再起。他尝试了各种方法来维持生计。他卖过家庭安防系统。他为别人架设过976色情电话线路，好让人能跟女孩通话。他做过电话销售，时薪8美元。他半开玩笑地说自己是贫困劳动者，但依然住在温内特卡。
Soon, the bank began threatening to foreclose on his home. He got behind on his gas bill. And his relationship with his wife became volatile. Then his seven-year-old son got hit by a car.
很快，银行开始威胁要收回他的房子。他的煤气费逾期未付。他和妻子的关系变得紧张。然后，他7岁的儿子被车撞了。
As I go and try to get his medical bills paid for, the insurance company says to me, it's contributory negligence, we don't owe you anything. You're on your own. We were virtually empty. I've got no money. I've got $3,000 in hospital bills at the emergency room. I've got probably another $3,000 to $4,000 for his dental.
当我试图去支付他的医疗费时，保险公司对我说，这是共同过失，我们不欠你任何东西。你自己解决吧。我们几乎一无所有。我还有3000美元的急诊室医院账单。我可能还得付另外3000到4000美元的牙科账单。
All his teeth were cracked, and they didn't know how they were going to put them back together. And there was a reminder every day of his injuries when I saw him. To see this kid suffering like he was, the pressure that I was under and the guilt I felt for not providing for him and not knowing what I was going to do about that, that was the part that really put it over the edge for me.
他所有的牙齿都裂了，他们不知道该怎么把它们接回去。我每天看到他时，都会想起他的伤情。看到孩子像那样受苦，我承受的压力，以及因为没能供养他而感受到的内疚，不知道该怎么办，那才是真正让我崩溃的部分。
So Bill Thompson made a plan. He finds his son's plastic toy pistol, which he and his wife had taken away from him because they didn't want him playing with guns. He steals a license plate from a parked car and, with magnets, attaches it to the rear of his van. And he puts on his Burberry raincoat and a Chicago Cubs cap.
所以比尔·汤普森制定了一个计划。他找到了儿子那把塑料玩具枪，那是他和妻子因为不想让孩子玩枪而收走的。他从一辆停着的车上偷了一个牌照，用磁铁贴在自己面包车的后面。他穿上那件巴宝莉（Burberry）雨衣，戴上一顶芝加哥小熊队的帽子。
The first time, I was just scared to death. And I went into a dry cleaners. And I wait 'til everybody leaves, and I pretend like I've got some garment or something. And I say, "I've got a gun." And she looks at me, and she just looks quizzical. And she goes, "what?"
第一次的时候，我吓得要死。我走进一家干洗店。等所有人离开，我就装作拿着一件衣服之类的东西。我说，“我有一把枪。”她看着我，眼神疑惑。她说，“什么？”
And then I realized she doesn't speak English. She calls somebody up to the front of the register that speaks English. And now, the whole thing's blown, so I turn around and walk out. Well, nothing happened to me at that point. I said, well, next time, you should stick around to get the money.
然后我意识到她不会说英语。她叫了一个会说英语的人到收银台前面。事情彻底搞砸了，所以我转身走开。嗯，那时候我没发生什么事。我说，好吧，下次我得待着等拿到钱。
So the first one that's successful, I walk into a cleaners. I said, I had a gun, open the drawer. It was sort of like a learning process as I went along. It was scary. You could tell I was nervous. I didn't use any voice. I didn't act like I was going to jump the counter and pistol whip the guy or anything like that. It was more like I was panhandling. I think I got $180. It was enough to placate my wife at the time, as I recall. And it was just that simple. It wasn't simple emotionally or anything. But physically, it was a very simple thing to do.
所以，第一次成功的那次，我走进一家洗衣店。我说，我有一把枪，打开抽屉。这算是一个边做边学的过程。很可怕。你可以看出我很紧张。我没大声说话。我没表现得像要跳过柜台去用枪托砸那个人的头之类的。这更像是乞讨。我想我拿到了180美元。据我回忆，这足够安抚当时的妻子了。事情就是这么简单。在情感上一点也不简单，但在体力上，这是一件非常简单的事情。
I think I did two cleaners, a bakery store, and a cigar store. There was all sorts of things that can-- what they call-- go wrong. One time, I went in a dry cleaners down on Fourth and Linden in Wilmette. And I saw my neighbor in there. And I just ducked my head and walked out.
我想我抢了两家洗衣店、一家面包店和一家雪茄店。发生了很多可能——他们称之为——出错的事情。有一次，我走进威尔梅特（Wilmette）第四街和林登街交界处的一家干洗店。我看见我的邻居在里面。我就把头一缩，走开了。
Of course, Bill could have sold his house or his van, but he didn't. He was a doctor's son, raised with lots of money. He didn't want to disappoint his wife. And at the time, frankly, it was hard to imagine living anywhere else, which, in hindsight, he acknowledges was crazy.
当然，比尔本可以卖掉他的房子或面包车，但他没有。他是一个医生的儿子，从小就不缺钱。他不想让妻子失望。坦白说，当时真的很难想象住到别的地方去，事后看来，他承认那很疯狂。
It's totally irrational. My thinking is so twisted that I'm thinking that I've got to do it, or everything's going to come tumbling down. It doesn't really matter what happens to me. If I get caught, I get away from this terrible situation I'm in. What do I have to lose? To me, it was never really about money. It was just about surviving. And survival, then, meant maintaining a certain lifestyle that I couldn't maintain.
这完全是不理性的。我的思想扭曲到了极点，我以为我必须这样做，否则一切都会土崩瓦解。我身上发生什么并不重要。如果我被抓了，我就摆脱了我身处的这种可怕的情况。我有什么可失去的呢？对我来说，这从来不是为了钱。这只是为了生存。而当时的生存，意味着维持一种我无法维持的生活方式。
So I decide I'm not getting enough money, so I'm going to stick up a bank. I'm looking for something where I can pay the bills for a couple of months instead of $150 to go down and buy groceries. There's this bank in Wilmette on the corner of Ridge and Lake. It's a storefront bank. It's not really a bank with big pillars and all that stuff. It's in a strip mall.
所以我决定钱不够，我要去抢银行。我在寻找那种能让我付几个月账单的地方，而不是拿150美元去买杂货。威尔梅特里奇路（Ridge）和湖路（Lake）路口有一家银行。那是一家店面银行。它不是那种有巨大柱子之类的银行。它在一个带状商场里。
And I go in there. And I walk up to the teller, and I hand her the note. The note says, this is a bank robbery, I have a gun, put the money in the bag. And I had her put the money in the bag. And I walk. I'm not running or anything like that. I'm trying to be as calm as I can be. Nobody stops me.
我走进去。我走到柜员面前，递给她那张纸条。纸条上写着，这是一次银行抢劫，我有一把枪，把钱放进袋子里。我让她把钱放进袋子里。我走了出去。我没有奔跑或者类似的事情。我尽量保持冷静。没人拦我。
I walked out and drove away. And I think it was something like $900, which gets it so that I can pay some bills. And I remember, at that point, right after that one, I remember being a little bit happy. But the pressure is still on. So I got to go do another bank.
我走出去开车走了。我想大概有900美元左右，这样我就可以付一些账单了。我记得在那一刻，就在那次之后，我记得有一点点高兴。但压力依然存在。所以我得去抢另一家银行。
So I go, and I find a little storefront bank. And so I finally muster up enough courage to go in there. And I make out the note and everything in my cryptic handwriting. And I walk in to the teller, and I hand her the note. And she looks at me, and she goes, "don't be ridiculous." She laughs at me. She says, "I'm not giving you any money."
所以我去了，我找到了一家小店面银行。我终于鼓足勇气走了进去。我用我那难以辨认的笔迹写好纸条等等。我走到柜员面前，把纸条递给她。她看着我，说，“别开玩笑了。”她嘲笑我。她说，“我才不会给你钱。”
And so I'm just totally shocked. I said, well, aren't these people supposed to do what you say when you're robbing a bank? And this woman says, "dpm't be ridiculous, get out of here." And so I leave. I was told what to do, so I just leave.
所以我完全惊呆了。我说，嗯，抢劫银行时，这些人不是应该乖乖听话吗？那个女人说，“别开玩笑了，滚出去。”所以我走了。我被告知该怎么做，所以我只能离开。
And so I get out, and I started driving, thinking, well, that was bad. And so it's only about four blocks away from the police station or five blocks or whatever. Evidently, they spotted the van. And so I was arrested, and it was over.
我出来后开始开车，心想，好吧，这太糟糕了。距离警察局只有四个街区或五个街区之类的。显然，他们发现了那辆面包车。所以我被捕了，一切都结束了。
I was just relieved that my life was going to change at that point. And I didn't know whether it would be for the worse or the better or anything else. It was one of those things where I was just relieved.
我只是感到宽慰，我的生活在那一刻终于要改变了。我不知道是会变得更糟还是更好。就是那种感觉，我只是感到宽慰。
Bill Thompson spent four years in prison, where the gangbangers nicknamed him Homer because they thought, with his pot belly and bald head, he looked like Homer Simpson. Bill's now trying to get on with his life. He got divorced. And last I spoke with him, he was involved in a business, exporting sporting goods to China. He's ashamed of this episode in his life, though he does mention it on his resume, presumably because employers will eventually find out anyway. But the hardest thing has been trying to rebuild his relationship with his children. To admit what he did without having it define him forever.
比尔·汤普森在监狱里度过了四年，那里的帮派成员给他起了个绰号叫“荷马”，因为他们觉得他挺着大肚子，光着头，看起来像辛普森一家里的荷马。比尔现在正试图继续他的生活。他离婚了。我最后一次和他交谈时，他参与了一项生意，向中国出口体育用品。他为自己生命中的这段插曲感到羞耻，尽管他在简历上提到了它，大概是因为雇主迟早也会查出来。但最困难的事情是试图重建与孩子们的亲子关系。承认他做过的事，而不让这件事定义他一生。
When I spent a couple of years in a Chicago housing project researching a book, I was struck by the power of suburban status symbols. Even there, the local gang's car of choice was a Chevrolet Suburban Blazer. At the time, teenagers were wearing Tommy Hilfiger and Guess. Hush Puppies and Coach wallets came and went. But while there was this yearning to appear prosperous, what was also clear is that for those without money, a little cash-- and I'm talking $10, $20, $50-- can go a long way to making life bearable.
当我花几年时间在芝加哥保障房项目研究一本书时，郊区的身份象征的力量令我震惊。即使在那里，当地帮派的首选车型也是雪佛兰Suburban Blazer。当时，青少年们穿着Tommy Hilfiger和Guess。Hush Puppies和Coach钱包来来去去。但在渴望显得富有的同时，显而易见的是，对于那些没有钱的人来说，一点点现金——我说的是10美元、20美元、50美元——就能让生活变得好过很多。
People come to me, they need money. If you have nowhere else to turn, if you need $50, you can't go to your bank and get a loan for $50. You can't go to your mother or your sister or your cousin or your friend. If you got nowhere else to go, I'm your last hope.
人们来找我，他们需要钱。如果你无处可去，如果你需要50美元，你不能去银行贷款50美元。你不能找你的母亲、姐妹、堂兄弟或朋友。如果你无处可去，我就是你最后的希望。
This is Dan Lebo. He helps run the family business, Chicago Pawners and Jewelers. It's in a pretty rough neighborhood on Chicago's West Side. Here's how a pawn shop works. People bring in items to pawn, like jewelry or stereos, and then, to retrieve them, they have to pay back the cash they originally got for their item plus interest, which is regulated by the state. All transactions are reported to the police so that stolen goods can be detected.
这是丹·勒博（Dan Lebo）。他协助经营家族企业，芝加哥当铺和珠宝店。它位于芝加哥西区一个相当艰苦的社区。当铺是这样运作的。人们带东西来典当，比如珠宝或音响，然后为了取回，他们必须偿还他们最初获得现金加上利息，利息由州政府监管。所有交易都向警方报告，以便发现被盗物品。
The stereotype is 90% of my customers are criminals. Everything we take in is stolen. It's dark and dim, and it's a seedy place, where people do seedy things. People don't know that 80% of my customers come back to get their stuff. People don't come to pawn once. Sometimes they pawn the same item 20 times. Sometimes they pawn it 50 times. Sometimes they pawn it once a week. Many of my customers are repeat customers. They come once or twice a month over a course of years. I get to know them pretty well.
刻板印象是90%的顾客都是罪犯。我们收到的所有东西都是偷来的。那里光线昏暗，是个肮脏的地方，人们在那里做着肮脏的事。人们不知道我80%的顾客都会回来取走他们的东西。人们不会只典当一次。有时他们典当同一件物品20次。有时他们典当50次。有时他们每周典当一次。我的许多顾客都是回头客。他们多年来每月来一两次。我能很好地了解他们。
My name is Mike. I do a lot of business with these guys over here. I've been dealing with them for about 30 years, maybe, 30, 40 years.
我叫迈克。我和这些人做生意很多。我和他们打交道大概30年了，也许30、40年。
Michael is in his 40s. He's got a wife. He works in the maintenance department at public schools. I am his Sears Roebuck. He buys a television if he needs it. If he needs a birthday gift, if he needs some money, he buys his jewelry from me. There's a lot of people who use my store almost like a convenience store. It's close.
迈克尔40多岁。他有个妻子。他在公立学校维修部门工作。我是他的西尔斯百货（Sears Roebuck）。他需要电视就来买。如果需要生日礼物，如果需要钱，他就从我这里买珠宝。很多人几乎把我的店当作便利店。离得近。
What's up, Vernon?
弗农，怎么了？
Hey, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
嘿，（无法辨认）。（无法辨认）。
Golden, right?
黄金的，对吧？
Yeah. Vernon.
是的，弗农。
I know that.
我知道。
I know Joe is a bus driver. I know Steve works in the public schools. People come to my window, and I would hear their stories.
我知道乔是个公交车司机。我知道史蒂夫在公立学校工作。人们来到我的窗口，我会听到他们的故事。
I'm going just down to a funeral down in Kentucky. And I just figured I needed some gas money. I ain't getting paid yet.
我要去肯塔基州参加葬礼。我只是觉得我需要一些油钱。我还没发工资。
Now how much would you give me if I sell this back?
那么如果我把它卖回来，你会给我多少钱？
What is that, an Uzi?
那是什么，乌兹冲锋枪？
No, it's a violin. Don't play with me. Today is Precious' birthday. I need some money. I'm want to go buy her some bookbags, one of the roller caddies that you put the books in.
不，那是小提琴。别跟我开玩笑了。今天是Precious的生日。我需要钱。我想去给她买些书包，那种放书用的带滚轮的推车。
They would tell me, this is what I need, this is my problem. My car broke down, or my lights are going to be turned off. Or my son is in jail, I have to bail him out. I need clothes for my kids to go to school.
他们会告诉我，我需要这个，这是我的问题。我的车坏了，或者我的电费要断了。或者我儿子在监狱里，我必须保释他。我需要给孩子们买上学的衣服。
I'm going to National Louis University. So today is the first day of class, and I need to buy a bus pass for school. And the financial aid hasn't kicked in yet.
我要去国立路易斯大学（National Louis University）。今天是开学第一天，我需要买一张学校的公交卡。助学金还没到账。
Hi.
嗨。
I wanted to know how much I will get for these.
我想知道我能换多少钱。
How much you trying to borrow?
你想借多少？
I don't know. What's the most I can get for them?
我不知道。我能拿到的最高金额是多少？
Those were one of those instances where it tugs at your heart a little bit. A woman came in at first, and there was a pair of hoop or little cluster earrings that they had. The question was, well, how much do you need. And she had no idea. It was one of those things. She's never done this before.
那些是那种让人揪心的例子之一。一个女人首先走进来，她拿出一对耳环。问题是，你需要多少钱。她一点头绪都没有。这就是那种情况。她从没做过这种事。
Well, I won't make you an offer. I like to have an idea of what you're trying to borrow. Give me an idea.
好吧，我不给你报价。我喜欢先有个大概想法。给我个大概。
I'm going to tell my boyfriend to come in here because he's the one who paid for them.
我要告诉我的男朋友进来，因为是他买的。
She just goes, let me go get my husband.
她只是说，让我去叫我丈夫。
Well, you need money. Do you need it for a bill or whatever?
好吧，你需要钱。你是为了账单之类的吗？
It's for a funeral.
是为了葬礼。
Oh. Basically, how much more money do you need for that?
噢。基本上，你还需要多少钱？
And the husband comes back in.
然后丈夫回来了。
How much did you want to borrow?
你想借多少钱？
He says he needs $800.
他说他需要800美元。
I don't know, $800 maybe. But I want to see how much-- I don't know how much you could borrow.
我不知道，800美元也许。但我想看看能换多少——我不知道你能借多少钱。
And they were something that I would sell in my store for probably less than $200. I'm thinking this in my head.
那些东西如果我在店里卖，可能不到200美元。我心里在想这个。
What'd you say? $800?
你说什么？800美元？
Yeah, I was.
是的，我之前想的是这个数。
I just tell them, I'm sorry, I can't help.
我只是告诉他们，抱歉，我帮不了。
That's OK. Thanks.
没关系。谢谢。
OK? Sorry.
好吧？抱歉。
Thanks a lot.
非常感谢。
Those are the things that hurt because you can't help them. Because they were just nothing of substance, nothing that I could really loan money on to help them or get them anywhere close to what they needed. And they went on their way. And I don't think they came back.
那些是让人难过的事情，因为你帮不了他们。因为它们本质上没什么价值，不是我真的能抵押借钱、帮他们解决问题的东西。他们就那样离开了。我想他们没再回来。
Let's see, you had $50. You had $80, is that right?
让我看看，你拿了50美元。你拿了80美元，对吧？
Please, could you spring me another $10? Please? I'm coming back to get it in two weeks.
求求你了，能再给我10美元吗？求你了？我两周后回来赎回它。
What'd you want? Another $10?
你想要什么？再要10美元？
Yeah, give me another $10. I'll work with that. I love you. Thank you.
对，再给我10美元。我会处理好的。我爱你。谢谢。
All right.
好吧。
She gets more than most people do just because she's been coming here for 1,000 years, in and out.
她拿到的比大多数人都多，只是因为她来这儿有一千年了，进进出出。
But I know my stuff's safe. You know what I'm saying? Can't leave it at home. I'll walk around with the stuff in my purse. That's bad.
但我知道我的东西很安全。你明白我的意思吗？不能留在家里。我会把这些东西放在钱包里走来走去。那太糟了。
I find all too often that people don't like leaving their jewelry or their valuables in their house. For them, they think it's safer to be in the store. It's almost like a safety deposit box. Unfortunately, in the business, a family member taking from another family member happens all the time. Some customers, their son has a problem. Their son's friend has a problem, their nephew, their cousin.
我经常发现人们不喜欢把珠宝或贵重物品放在家里。对他们来说，放在店里更安全。几乎就像一个保险箱。不幸的是，在这行，家庭成员偷走另一个家庭成员的东西经常发生。有些顾客，他们的儿子有问题。儿子的朋友有问题，侄子、表亲都有问题。
This was probably 8, 10 years ago. This particular gentleman would pawn a guitar. Didn't think anything of it. But a couple days later, an older gentleman would come in with the pawn ticket and pick up the guitar. He would pawn it and be picked up, pawn it and be picked up. This would go on.
那可能是8、10年前了。这位绅士会典当一把吉他。没多想什么。但几天后，一位老先生会拿着当票进来把吉他赎回去。他会典当，然后被赎走，典当，然后被赎走。这事儿没完没了。
And we would say, who's the person who pawns it? Well, that's my son. Oh, he stole it from the church, and I'm getting it back because we need it. And part of the question we would ask the father, we'd say, well, what would you like us to do? Because we could say, we don't have to take in the guitar. Because what ends up happening, the son gets the money. The father then has to come in and pay his money to get the guitar back.
我们会问，谁典当的？嗯，那是我儿子。哦，他从教堂偷的，我把它赎回来因为我们还要用它。我们问父亲的一个问题是，你希望我们怎么做？因为我们可以说，我们不必收下这把吉他。因为最后发生的事情是，儿子拿到了钱。父亲然后不得不花钱把吉他赎回来。
And the father would say, you have to take the guitar. Because otherwise, my son will sell it to some guy on the street, and then my guitar is gone. Take the guitar. I'll get it back. And that's pretty much the way it went.
父亲会说，你必须收下这把吉他。因为否则，我儿子会把它卖给街上的某个家伙，然后我的吉他就不见了。拿着这把吉他。我会把它赎回来的。事情基本上就是这样。
You remember the story I told you about the minister who took me for $250? Well, I conjured up ways to take revenge. I thought maybe I could publicly humiliate him by writing about the episode. Or better yet, I could show up at a Sunday service and expose him to his parishioners.
还记得我讲的那个收了我250美元的牧师的故事吗？嗯，我想出了各种报复的方法。我以为我可以通过写那个片段来公开羞辱他。或者更好的是，我可以出现在周日的礼拜上，向他的教区居民揭露他。
I thought about leafletting outside his church. I even went so far as to write the material for the leaflet. I shared all these possible tactics with my wife. But she rolled her eyes. Because in the end, I did nothing. I just walked away.
我想过在他的教堂外面散发传单。我甚至写好了传单的内容。我和妻子分享了所有这些可能的战术。但她翻了个白眼。因为最后，我什么也没做。我只是走开了。
Part of it, I was just too ashamed. I'm too easy a mark. Why advertise that? But the worst of it, I began to feel sorry for the guy. And I thought his stealing from me shouldn't nullify all the good things he did for my young friend, which brings me to my final story about money.
部分原因是，我太羞愧了。我太容易被骗了。为什么要宣扬这一点？但最糟糕的是，我开始同情那家伙。我认为他偷我的钱不应该抵消他为我年轻朋友所做的一切好事，这让我引出了关于金钱的最后一个故事。
This is not an easy story to tell about myself because I fancy myself as one of those guys who is not taken easily. I should've seen this guy coming, and I didn't. Because I wanted to believe this was it.
这不是一个容易讲述的关于我自己的故事，因为我自认为是那种不容易被骗的人。我本应该看穿这家伙的，但我没有。因为我愿意相信这就是真的。
This is my friend Tony Fitzpatrick. He's a successful artist who draws and paints these exquisite, boisterous prints inspired by his experiences in Chicago. You may be familiar with his work. He's done the album covers for Aaron Neville and Steve Earle. Well, early in Tony's career, when he was still struggling, Tony got seduced by a big time art dealer, a man named Vrej Baghoomian. He owned a gallery on Broadway in New York.
这是我的朋友托尼·菲茨帕特里克（Tony Fitzpatrick）。他是一位成功的艺术家，他根据在芝加哥的经历绘制了这些精致、喧闹的版画。你可能熟悉他的作品。他为亚伦·内维尔（Aaron Neville）和史蒂夫·厄尔（Steve Earle）做过专辑封面。嗯，在托尼职业生涯的早期，当他还在挣扎时，托尼被一位大牌艺术商诱惑了，一个名叫弗雷·巴古米安（Vrej Baghoomian）的人。他在纽约百老汇拥有一个画廊。
Boy, he was smooth. He smoked Dunhills. You know what I mean? This guy was European. I thought, this is it, this is my shot at making the majors. So I worked, and I worked, and I worked. And I kind of pushed away everything except the show.
天哪，他真圆滑。他抽邓希尔香烟。你明白我的意思吗？这家伙是欧洲人。我想，就是这个，这是我进入主流的机会。所以我工作，工作，再工作。我几乎推开了一切，只为了那个展览。
It was very difficult because my wife was more and more pregnant. And she was alone all the time. My big New York show was more important than anything. Because in my own rationalizations, that was what was going to take care of our newborn son and help buy us a home. And that's what was running through my head the whole time I was making this New York show. That all of a sudden, this chunk of dough was going to make me more respectable.
这非常困难，因为我妻子的怀孕程度越来越深。她一直孤身一人。我的大型纽约展览比任何事情都重要。因为在我自己的合理化中，那将是照顾我们刚出生的儿子并帮我们买房的东西。在我筹备纽约展览的整个过程中，这些想法一直在我的脑海里盘旋。突然之间，这一大笔钱会让我变得更体面。
So the show opens. Vrej isn't there. All of his staff, instead of being out in the open, talking to people, helping to sell stuff, is standing around Vrej's fax machine, staring at it. My Philadelphia dealer was there. And he said, let me take a look in the back room.
所以展览开幕了。弗雷不在。他所有的员工，本应该在开放空间里，与人交谈，帮忙卖东西，却站在弗雷的传真机旁，盯着它。我的费城代理商在那儿。他说，让我去后台看看。
So he went by the back room, looked in there. There were no paintings. There were no pieces of art back there. It was empty. That's when I knew the whole thing was circling the bowl. And we saw it coming. There was nothing we could do.
他走到后台，看了看。没有油画。后面没有艺术品。它是空的。就在那时我知道整件事快完了。我们预料到了。我们无能为力。
Now, in the meantime, me, my wife, and my Philadelphia dealer sold 21 pieces out of the show, probably about $50,000 to $60,000 worth of work. We flew back to Chicago.
现在，与此同时，我和我妻子以及我的费城代理商从展览中卖出了21件作品，价值大概在5万到6万美元左右。我们飞回了芝加哥。
And three days later, I got a call from a kid named Eric who worked at Vrej Baghoomian as just an art installer. And he said, look, the federal marshals are coming to padlock the gallery. Vrej has fled the country. All of the checks and all of the money that was paid for your work was taken by the staff and by Vrej. By this point, we had a three-week-old baby. I had to go home on a Saturday evening, and I had to tell my wife we didn't have any money. We were broke.
三天后，我接到一个叫埃里克的孩子的电话，他在弗雷·巴古米安那里只是个艺术装置安装工。他说，看，联邦法警要来给画廊加锁了。弗雷已经逃离了这个国家。所有支付你作品的支票和金钱都被员工和弗雷拿走了。到了这个时候，我们有一个三周大的孩子。周六晚上我不得不回家，不得不告诉妻子我们没钱了。我们破产了。
I was out $40,000. And I let it be known to anybody who cared or anybody in the art world that eventually I was going to catch up with Vrej Baghoomian. Five years ago, I'm on Green Street in New York with my buddy Mickey [? Carton. ?] And this kind of older, Middle Eastern guy walks up, and he goes, Tony, Tony, good to see you, Tony. Shakes my hand, gives me a little European hug, and walks away.
我亏了4万美元。我让任何关心的人或艺术界的任何人知道，我迟早会抓到弗雷·巴古米安。五年前，我在纽约绿街（Green Street）和我的好友米基·卡顿在一起。那个老一点的中东男人走过来，他说，托尼，托尼，见到你真高兴，托尼。握了握我的手，给了我一个欧洲式的拥抱，然后走开了。
It took me about 20 seconds to realize, that's Vrej. Now, I've been telling everybody in the art world, when I see him, I'm going to kick his ass, I'm going to pound $40,000 worth of misery out of his hide. I didn't do any of those things. I said, hey, Vrej, wait up. And he turned to me, and he looked really old.
我花了大约20秒才意识到，那是弗雷。现在，我一直在告诉艺术界的每个人，当我见到他，我要揍他，我要从他身上压榨出4万美元的痛苦。我没做这些事。我说，嘿，弗雷，等一下。他转身看着我，看起来真的很老。
I was the least of his problems of guys he owed money to. He had borrowed money from loan sharks, guys who were barely legal in that business, guys who would send guys if you didn't pay up. He was really beaten down, and he looked it. So I said, Vrej, how are you? And he said, I've been ill. And I said, I heard that. And he said, some day, we should really talk. And he shook my hand again and ran off.
在他亏欠钱的人中，我是最不重要的一个。他向高利贷者借过钱，那些人在那行几乎不合法，你不还钱就会派人来的家伙。他真的被打垮了，看起来就是那样。所以我说，弗雷，你好吗？他说，我一直生病。我说，我听说了。他说，哪天，我们真的应该谈谈。他又握了握我的手，跑了。
So I got back to Mickey. And Mickey said, yeah, there's your pal. There's Vrej Baghoomian. Yeah, this is the guy you're going to kick his ass, you're going to pound him up one side of Broadway and down the other. And you didn't do anything. And I didn't.
所以我回到米基那儿。米基说，是啊，这就是你的哥们。那是弗雷·巴古米安。是啊，这就是你要揍的那个家伙，你要把他在百老汇的一边揍到另一边的人。而你什么也没做。而我确实没做。
The more and more I thought about it, the more my anger was tempered by just feeling stupid for wanting those things, the grand prize, the big New York art world. I can never, ever again let this be about money. I learned that the real value of making art is everything you go through while you're making it. And the long and short of it, I still had the show. I was still the author of all those pieces. I still had an opening night full of the best work at that point in my life that I'd ever made.
我越想这件事，我的愤怒就越是被那种想得到那些东西——大奖、大型纽约艺术圈——的愚蠢感所抵消。我绝不能再让这件事与金钱有关了。我明白艺术创作的真正价值在于你在创作过程中经历的一切。总而言之，我依然拥有那个展览。我依然是所有那些作品的作者。我依然有一个开幕之夜，那里满是我当时人生中创作出的最棒的作品。
When I go to the Art Institute, I run to one place. I go to Gallery 236 and 237, and I look at the Joseph Cornell boxes. They're these tiny things with little glass pipes in them and star charts and sand and dolls and cutouts of birds and chicken wire. He took all of this inert stuff and made these magical, little environments. And I have never-- never once when I looked at that work did I ever wonder what it costs.
当我去艺术学院，我跑向一个地方。我去236和237画廊，看着约瑟夫·康奈尔（Joseph Cornell）的盒子。那是些微小的东西，里面有玻璃管、星图、沙子、玩偶、鸟剪纸和铁丝网。他把所有这些惰性物质变成了这些神奇的小环境。我从来——从来没有一次当我看着那些作品时，想过它值多少钱。
Tony Fitzpatrick. Alex Kotlowitz is a reporter. Amy Drozdowska-McGuire, the producer. Alex is the author of many books, including There Are No Children Here and now, most recently, Never a City So Real. Versions of these stories originally appeared on Chicago Public Radio's series Chicago Matters, which gets funding from the Chicago Community Trust. Executive producer of that series is Julia McEvoy.
托尼·菲茨帕特里克。亚历克斯·科特洛维茨是一位记者。艾米·德罗兹多夫斯卡-麦奎尔（Amy Drozdowska-McGuire）是制片人。亚历克斯是许多书的作者，包括《这里没有孩子》（There Are No Children Here）以及最近的《没有一个城市如此真实》（Never a City So Real）。这些故事的版本最初出现在芝加哥公共广播的系列节目“芝加哥事务”（Chicago Matters）中，该节目获得了芝加哥社区信托基金（Chicago Community Trust）的资助。该系列的执行制片人是朱莉娅·麦克沃伊（Julia McEvoy）。
Coming up, John Hodgman gets on the wrong side of an entire mall. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，约翰·霍奇曼站在了商场的对立面。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Getting and Spending, stories about what people think they have to do to make their money. That was the first half of the show. And in this half of the program, what they think they have to do to spend their money. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two-- That Guy.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，“获取与支出”，关于人们认为为了赚钱必须做的事情的故事。那是节目的前半部分。而在节目的这一半，是关于他们认为为了花钱必须做的事情。我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕——“那个人”。
Now, I think about this next story as a story about spending money. Though I have to say, the person who did this story, one of our producers, Diane Cook, hates it when I say that that's what this story is about. She points out, and I guess I agree, that this story is about so much more than just how you spend your money. It's about a phenomenon that she notices all the time with people that she knows and people that she doesn't know. Here's Diane.
现在，我把这个接下来的故事看作一个关于花钱的故事。尽管我必须说，做这个故事的人，我们的制片人之一，黛安·库克（Diane Cook），讨厌我这么说这个故事。她指出，我也许同意，这个故事讲述的不仅仅是如何花钱。它是关于她一直在她认识的人和她不认识的人身上注意到的一个现象。下面有请黛安。
When my boyfriend, Jorge, was a teenager and started to use deodorant, he had to choose which kind to buy. He tried a bunch of different brands. But Old Spice reminded him too much of sailors, Right Guard made him feel like he needed to be playing basketball all the time, and Arrid Extra Dry was way too intense of a name for the moderate climate he lived in. So he settled on an innocuous, nondescript brand, Mitchum.
当我的男朋友乔治还是个青少年开始使用除臭剂时，他不得不选择买哪一种。他试过很多不同的品牌。但Old Spice让他想起水手，Right Guard让他觉得必须时刻在打篮球，而Arrid Extra Dry对他所处的温和气候来说名字太强了。所以他选择了一个无害、不显眼的品牌，Mitchum。
It's old. It's been around forever. And the reason it's been around forever is because people use it. And not enough people use it that there's a kind of person that uses it. And not too few people use it that you're making a statement. It's just deodorant. It doesn't make me feel cool. It doesn't make me feel uncool. Makes me feel like I'm putting deodorant on.
它很老。它存在很久了。它能存在这么久是因为人们使用它。并没有足够多的人使用它以至于形成一种“使用这种产品的人群”。也没有太少人使用它以至于这变成一种“声明”。它只是除臭剂。它不让我觉得酷。也不让我觉得不酷。它让我觉得我只是在涂除臭剂。
Fast forward 15 years. Jorge lives in New York. He boards a subway car one morning. And with nothing to read, he turns his attention to an ad on the train.
快进15年。乔治住在纽约。一天早上他上了地铁。由于没什么可读的，他把注意力转向了车厢里的广告。
I start reading it, and it's just this ridiculous ad. It's a ridiculous message about being able to kick in the windows of a train in an emergency. And it's like, you're a tough guy if you can do this. I'm reading it. I'm like, this is stupid, this is stupid, this is stupid.
我开始读它，只是个荒谬的广告。这是一个关于在紧急情况下能踢开火车车窗的荒谬信息。就像是，如果你能做到这一点，你就是个硬汉。我读着它。我心想，这太蠢了，这太蠢了，这太蠢了。
And so I get to the punch line or whatever. This is about Mitchum. What it actually says is, if you're pretty sure you could kick in a window in the event of an emergency, then you're a Mitchum man. And you look around, the entire train is plastered with ads. And they're all ads for Mitchum.
所以我看到了笑点或者类似的什么东西。这是关于Mitchum的。它真正说的是，如果你非常确定在紧急情况下能踢开一扇窗，那么你就是个Mitchum男人。你四处看看，整辆车都贴满了广告。它们全是Mitchum的广告。
And they're all like, if you've ever vaulted over anything in order to catch a train, you're a Mitchum man. If you are a total prick, then you're a Mitchum man. It's just completely and utterly embarrassing because I'm not that guy. I don't think that. I think, shoot, I missed the train. You know what I mean?
它们全是那种：如果你曾经为了赶火车而跳过什么东西，你就是个Mitchum男人。如果你是个十足的混蛋，那么你就是个Mitchum男人。这完全彻底让人尴尬，因为我不是那种人。我不那么想。我心想，该死，我错过火车了。你明白我的意思吗？
Everyone stay seated and remain calm while there's an emergency.
请大家坐好，保持冷静，发生紧急情况时。
I'm sure we'll be moving soon. There must be a reasonable explanation for this.
我相信我们很快就会移动的。一定有一个合理的解释。
So OK, his deodorant has a lame ad campaign. So what? And it didn't matter to Jorge until he found himself standing in the deodorant aisle at the supermarket a week later and staring at the Michtum, unable to reach his arm out, pick it up, and put it in his basket.
好吧，他的除臭剂有一个烂广告。那又怎样？这对乔治来说无关紧要，直到一周后他发现自己站在超市的除臭剂货架前，盯着Mitchum，却无法伸出手去捡起它并放进篮子里。
I thought that if I bought the Mitchum, I was going to take it to the checkout line, and I was going to put it there, and the person at the grocery line was going to think that I was trying Mitchum for the first time because of the advertising. There's nothing about Mitchum that it would be obvious to somebody that, hey, he's been using Mitchum for 10, 15 years. You know what I mean?
我以为如果我买了Mitchum，我会带它去结账，然后把它放在那儿，超市收银台的人会以为我是因为广告第一次尝试Mitchum。没有任何东西能明显看出，嘿，他已经用了Mitchum 10、15年了。你明白我的意思吗？
If it was-- I don't know-- Old English shaving cream, and I'm wearing a top hat, and I'm 70 years old, and they started a marketing campaign, they could be like, oh, that guy has been using that stuff forever. The beauty of the brand is that there's nothing associated with it. So as soon as they make this whole Mitchum man campaign, all of a sudden, you cannot help, but be like, anybody you see buying Mitchum is just going to instantly be like, hey, they must love those Mitchum man ads.
如果它是——不知道——Old English剃须膏，而且我戴着高礼帽，我70岁了，他们开始了一个营销活动，他们可能会想，哦，那家伙一直用那个东西。这个品牌的魅力在于它没有什么关联。所以一旦他们做了这个整个Mitchum男人的活动，突然之间，你不得不觉得，任何你看到买Mitchum的人都会立刻觉得，嘿，他们一定喜欢那些Mitchum男人广告。
He left the store deodorant-less, which in and of itself is pretty embarrassing. He doesn't want to be the guy who buys Mitchum because of the ads. But does he really want to be the guy who boycotts Mitchum because of the ads? How far do you want to go to make sure you're not that guy?
他空手离开了商店，这本身就够尴尬的了。他不想成为那个因为广告而买Mitchum的人。但他真的想成为那个因为广告而抵制Mitchum的人吗？你想走多远来确保你不是那个人？
I think of this as the that-guy phenomenon. It starts with someone you're repulsed by or simply never wanted to be. And then one day, you realize you are that guy.
我认为这被称为“那个人”现象。它始于你反感或仅仅是从未想过要成为的某个人。然后有一天，你意识到你就是那个人。
My friend Mike was a troublemaker in school, and he hated the authority figures who caught him breaking the rules. Now he's the vice principal in charge of busting kids like him. And another friend of mine, who I hadn't heard from in years, emailed me to let me know that she was getting divorced. She's young, 29, and she couldn't believe the course that her life had taken. The last line in her email was, I can't believe I'm that girl. Or take Brett. He has steadfastly resisted one of the travel industry's greatest inventions, wheeled luggage, because he doesn't want to be a wheeled luggage guy.
我的朋友迈克在学校是个麻烦制造者，他讨厌那些抓住他破坏规则的权威人物。现在他是负责打击像他那样孩子的副校长。而我的另一个朋友，我多年没联系的，给我发邮件说她要离婚了。她很年轻，29岁，她无法相信她的人生竟然走到了这一步。她邮件的最后一行是：我不相信我竟然成了那个女孩。或者看看布雷特。他坚定地抵制了旅游业最伟大的发明之一：带轮行李箱，因为他不想成为一个“带轮行李箱的人”。
The people who have wheeled luggage are assistant sales managers going to conferences someplace or old ladies, and they're not real travelers.
那些有带轮行李箱的人是去开会的助理销售经理，或者是老太太，他们不是真正的旅行者。
For Brett, the only thing a real traveler needs is a backpack.
对布雷特来说，真正的旅行者唯一需要的就是背包。
I don't need no wheels. I can carry everything. It was years and years that I would be lugging this huge backpack through airports, sneering at the people who were wheeling their thing behind them. If you can breeze through the airport, pulling your thing without breaking a sweat, somehow you're not having the full experience.
我不需要轮子。我可以背起一切。多年来，我一直拖着这个巨大的背包穿过机场，嘲笑着那些拖着箱子的人。如果你能轻而易举地穿过机场，拉着你的东西而不出一身汗，某种程度上你并没有获得完整的体验。
The backpack he used was the backpack of his youth. He had taken it on trips to Europe, Asia, and the Middle East. Every scuff or stain on it had a story. He'd even slept on it.
他用的那个背包是他年轻时的背包。他带着它去过欧洲、亚洲和中东旅行。上面的每一处磨损或污渍都有一个故事。他甚至睡在它上面。
It's not going too far to say that from Brett's perspective, his backpack is what made him an individual. He was different from the sea of look-alike businessmen, running through the airport with their wheeled luggage. And he liked being different. But then, at age 30, he realized, the thing that made them different from him is that they were getting everywhere faster and without leg cramps.
从布雷特的角度来看，说他的背包让他与众不同并不为过。他与那些拖着带轮行李箱在机场奔跑的千篇一律的商人不同。他喜欢与众不同。但后来，在30岁时，他意识到，让他们与他不同的地方在于他们能更快地到达任何地方，而且不会腿抽筋。
If this dilemma sounds a little ridiculous to you, remember, for a moment, your own attitude, once upon a time, about cell phones. You were never going to be that guy yapping away on his phone. But now you are. And why? Because at this point, the only reason not to have a cell phone is to be that guy who refuses to join the club, which isn't cool.
如果这个困境听起来对你来说有点荒谬，请暂时回忆一下你曾经对手机的态度。你永远不会成为那个在电话里没完没了地唠叨的家伙。但现在你是了。为什么？因为在这一点上，不带手机的唯一理由就是成为那个拒绝入会的家伙，那一点也不酷。
At some point, the embarrassment of becoming that guy who worries about becoming that guy outweighs the ego of carrying your thing. Because we're talking about the wheel. It's the most basic caveman technology imaginable. It's like saying, I'm not going to use fire to cook my meat because it's too bourgeois or something like that. A monkey can figure out that it's easier to use a wheel to pull something than it is to carry it on your back.
在某种程度上，成为那个担心成为那个人的人的尴尬感，超过了携带你的东西的自我意识。因为我们谈论的是轮子。它是你能想象到的最基本的穴居人技术。这就像说，我不会用火来烤肉，因为它太资产阶级了或者是别的什么。猴子都能弄明白用轮子拉东西比背着它更容易。
I've had a lot of that guy moments. But possibly, the most sobering one went like this. As a kid, I spent a lot of time in model homes and open houses. My mom would drag me to them every weekend. We'd wander through, surrounded by other women my mom's age and their unfortunate children.
我有很多“那个人”时刻。但可能最令人清醒的一次是这样的。小时候，我花了很多时间在样板房和开放参观房屋中。我妈妈每个周末都会把我拖到那里。我们在里面漫步，被其他我妈妈这个年纪的妇女和她们不幸的孩子包围着。
But none of it ever made any sense to me. I knew for a fact we weren't moving, totally not in the market for a house. And yet, we were there, my mom running her hand over the newly upholstered sofa or marveling at their gleaming, white kitchen.
但这一切对我来说毫无意义。我确定我们不会搬家，完全没有买房的需求。然而，我们却在那里，我妈妈在刚换过衬里的沙发上抚摸，或者对着他们闪闪发光的白色厨房赞叹。
I hated these afternoons. The houses were so different from ours. And I knew that my mom thought that they were better. We were there to covet what they had, and we didn't. I vowed to myself I'd never be the kind of person who did this.
我讨厌这些下午。这些房子和我们的完全不同。我知道我妈妈认为它们更好。我们在那里是为了垂涎他们拥有的东西，而我们没有。我发誓永远不会成为那种这样做的人。
Then one sunny day, at the ripe age of 26, driving down my street past a condo for sale, I spotted an open house sign. And for reasons I can't explain, I was overcome with delight. I squealed. I actually squealed, an open house. Then turning to my boyfriend, let's go in and see what it's like. Then I froze. I had become that guy, and that guy was my mom.
后来阳光明媚的一天，在26岁的花样年华，开着车经过我住的街道，经过一栋待售的公寓，我发现了一个开放参观的标志。出于我无法解释的原因，我感到狂喜。我尖叫。我真的尖叫了，开放参观。然后转向我的男朋友，我们进去看看它是什么样的。然后我僵住了。我已经变成了那个人，而那个人就是我妈妈。
You can only fight so much what you're going to become. It's going to be there waiting for you in the end because it's just true, some of it. Wheels are better. Although I have to say, it's a little embarrassing. But I still don't have the classic, black pull-along. Mine are cooler. I've got some kind of flaps or color on it or something like that. So I haven't entirely given in.
对于你将要成为什么样的人，你只能做有限的抗争。最终它会等在那里，因为这是真的，有些东西。轮子确实更好。虽然我必须说，这有点尴尬。但我依然没有那种经典的黑色拖轮箱。我的更酷一些。上面有某种翻盖或颜色什么的。所以我还没完全屈服。
I've been battling my own little open house problem too. But it's useless. I'm too ashamed to bring myself to actually walk through an open house. So instead, when I need to blow off a little steam, I just look through the online real estate section, at all the pictures of ornate bathroom faucets and sunny, colorful living rooms, pouring over it like it was ladies' porn.
我也一直在和自己的一点点开放参观问题作斗争。但没用。我太羞愧了，不敢亲自进去参观。所以，当我想发泄一下的时候，我就看看在线房地产板块，看所有那些华丽的浴室水龙头和阳光明媚、色彩鲜艳的客厅的图片，仔细研读，就像它是女士的色情读物一样。
Diane Cook is one of the producers of our program.
黛安·库克是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "THAT GUY", THE FAMILY GUY]
（音乐 - “那个人”，《恶搞之家》）
Act Three, Mall Rat. And we close our program on Getting and Spending with a trip to a place where gobs of that is happening. To take us there, here's John Hodgman.
第三幕，“商场老鼠”。在“获取与支出”这个主题上，我们以一趟前往发生这些事情的地方的旅行来结束我们的节目。带我们去那里的是约翰·霍奇曼。
Some years ago, I was a contributing editor to a national magazine of men's fitness and adventure, where I wrote about food, drink, and cheese, which is a kind of food. In my several years as a professional food journalist, I wrote exactly two stories the magazine refused to publish.
几年前，我是一本全国性男性健身与探险杂志的特约编辑，我在那儿写关于食物、饮料和奶酪——一种食物——的文章。在我担任专业食品记者的几年里，我写过两篇杂志拒绝刊登的文章。
The first was on ultra-hot hot sauces. An example of an ultra-hot hot sauce is Dave's Insanity Sauce, which I ate on a little cracker once. And then my head hurt, and then I had to lie down. And then I was crying for a day or so.
第一篇是关于超辣辣酱。超辣辣酱的一个例子是Dave's Insanity Sauce，我有次在饼干上吃了一点。然后我的头就开始痛，然后我不得不躺下。然后我哭了整整一天左右。
Dave's is actually on the milder end of the ultra-hot hot sauce spectrum. There is an entire category of ultra-hot hot sauces that promises death. I recognize that death is a part of life. Still, I could not bring myself to endorse death by ultra-hotness, which is perhaps why my magazine found my piece quote unquote, "overly gay."
Dave's实际上处于超辣辣酱光谱中较温和的一端。有一整个超辣辣酱类别是承诺会带来死亡的。我承认死亡是生活的一部分。尽管如此，我还是无法强迫自己支持“超辣带来的死亡”，这也许就是为什么我的杂志发现我的文章被引用为“过于同性恋”。
The second article of mine that was never published was about the food court at the Mall of America. I was excited to visit the nation's largest mall, but what I discovered there shocked me. It also apparently shocked my magazine, which refused to publish it on the pretense that quote, "Most of it was made up," and that quote, "It did not involve perfect abs, or sea kayaking, or the best hamburgers ever, or incredible sex tips for having sex with Jessica Alba, or the fighting of polar bears," unquote, which I knew was their nice way of saying, overly gay. But you, dear listener, shall not shy from what is revealed in this, my unedited private diary of the secrets of the Mall of America with all of the made up parts intact.
我未被刊登的第二篇文章是关于美国购物中心的食品广场。我很兴奋去参观这个国家最大的购物中心，但我发现的东西让我震惊。这也显然让我的杂志感到震惊，它拒绝刊登它，理由是引用“大部分是编造的”，并且引用“它不涉及完美的腹肌，或海上皮划艇，或有史以来最好的汉堡，或与杰西卡·阿尔芭发生性关系的绝佳性技巧，或与北极熊搏斗”，引用结束，我知道这是他们礼貌的说法，即“过于同性恋”。但是你，亲爱的听众，将不会回避这篇揭露的文章，这是我未编辑的私人日记，关于美国购物中心的秘密，所有编造的部分都完好无损。
Day one, at 200 million square feet, the Mall of America is the largest mall in the United States. In addition to 520 shops, 2/3 of which are devoted to the sale of FDNY and NYPD baseball caps, it has a chapel, and a school, and a post office, and an amusement park, called Camp Snoopy, inside of it. It is not, I should point out, the largest mall in North America. That distinction belongs to the West Edmonton Mall in Canada, which contains 7,000 baseball cap shops, and a sausage factory, an entire medieval castle, 12 monorails, and the entire township of East Edmonton, preserved like Pompeii at the exact moment it was devoured by the West Edmonton Mall.
第一天，美国购物中心占地2亿平方英尺，是美国最大的购物中心。除了520家商店，其中2/3致力于销售FDNY和NYPD棒球帽外，里面还有一个礼拜堂、一所学校、一个邮局，以及一个名为史努比营（Camp Snoopy）的游乐园。我应该指出，它不是北美最大的购物中心。那个头衔属于加拿大的西埃德蒙顿购物中心（West Edmonton Mall），它包含7000家棒球帽店、一家香肠厂、一座完整的中世纪城堡、12条单轨铁路，以及整个东埃德蒙顿镇，像庞贝古城一样被保存在被西埃德蒙顿购物中心吞噬的那一刻。
Still, the Mall of America is large enough that I can see it from my hotel room, literally hundreds of feet away. Its phosphor lights obliterate the Minnesota evening. It is so bright, I don't know how they get the giant bats to keep circling it.
尽管如此，美国购物中心很大，大到我可以从我的酒店房间看到它，字面上讲只有几百英尺远。它的磷光灯消灭了明尼苏达的夜晚。它太亮了，我不知道他们怎么让巨大的蝙蝠一直在它周围盘旋。
Day two, the Mall of America is filled with elderly people, always walking, circling the mall like sharks, they say, for exercise. When they collapse, mall security discreetly removes them and props them up in the booths at Johnny Rockets. One elderly woman has agreed to show me her favorite places to eat. Her name is Elaine.
第二天，美国购物中心里挤满了老年人，总是走动着，像鲨鱼一样绕着购物中心巡航，他们说，为了锻炼。当他们倒下时，商场保安会谨慎地把他们移走，并把他们支在Johnny Rockets的摊位上。一位老太太同意带我参观她最喜欢的餐馆。她叫伊莱恩。
She takes me into the Odyssey Cafe. It is a restaurant with four dining rooms, each decorated in the style of a lost civilization. I'm not very impressed by the Atlantis room, which is just a blue room with pictures of fish on the wall, not a single porthole, which, to me, just seems obvious.
她带我进了奥德赛咖啡馆（Odyssey Cafe）。那是一家有四个餐厅的餐馆，每一个都以失落文明的风格装饰。我对亚特兰蒂斯房间印象不深，它只是一个蓝色房间，墙上挂着鱼的照片，一个舷窗都没有，这对我来说似乎很明显。
But the Machu Picchu room is stunning with beautiful murals of mountain tops and very thin air, which makes it hard to breathe. And all the hard boiled eggs are undercooked. Also, the room is staffed by actual Incas, looking sad and doing their sad little math with knots of string when they are not serving you omelets. Elaine says, this is all that remains of their once-great civilization.
但马丘比丘房间令人惊叹，有着美丽的壁画，画着山顶，而且空气非常稀薄，让人难以呼吸。所有的水煮蛋都没熟。此外，房间里有真正的印加人负责，他们看起来很悲伤，不服务欧姆蛋的时候就在用细绳打结做他们悲伤的小数学。伊莱恩说，这就是他们曾经伟大的文明所剩的一切。
Day three, The Minnesota Picnic is a stand run by three brothers, all of them Egyptian. They serve traditional favorites of the Minnesota State Fair, pike on a stick, corn dogs on a stick, fried cheese curd, and bamya matboukha, the famous Egyptian okra stew, which unfortunately cannot be served on a stick. The brothers implore me to try their new invention, deep-fried cheesecake on a stick, a stunning breakthrough in food-on-a-stick technology.
第三天，明尼苏达野餐店（Minnesota Picnic）是一个由三兄弟经营的摊位，他们全是埃及人。他们供应明尼苏达州博览会的传统美食，带棍梭子鱼、带棍玉米热狗、炸奶酪凝乳，还有bamya matboukha，著名的埃及秋葵炖菜，遗憾的是它不能带棍供应。兄弟俩恳求我尝试他们的新发明，带棍油炸芝士蛋糕，这是带棍食品技术的一项惊人突破。
Then they admit they are sad, sad like the Incas are sad. After 10 years, the Mall of America is kicking them out, and they don't know why. Suddenly, this reporter smells more than frying oil. He smells a story. I ask if they think they are being discriminated against. Oh no, they say, oh, no, no, no, no, no.
然后他们承认他们很悲伤，像印加人一样悲伤。10年后，美国购物中心要把他们赶走，他们不知道为什么。突然，这位记者闻到的不仅仅是油炸味。他闻到了故事的味道。我问他们是否认为自己受到了歧视。噢不，他们说，噢，不，不，不，不，不。
Day four, I call the mall PR people to ask why they are exiling the Egyptians and also to ask about the secret tunnel I found that leads from Camp Snoopy to Pottery Barn and is lined with human skulls. This is when the Mall of America stops returning my calls. It happens sometimes when professional journalists ask the wrong questions. I'm frozen out. From here on in, I'm going rogue.
第四天，我打电话给商场的公关人员，问他们为什么要放逐埃及人，也问关于我发现的那条通往史努比营到Pottery Barn的秘密隧道，里面衬满了人类头骨。这是美国购物中心停止接听我电话的时候。当专业记者问错问题时，这种情况有时会发生。我被拒之门外。从现在起，我要单干了。
Day five, Elaine takes me to Cereal Adventure, which is a mini theme park run by General Mills, makers of Trix and Lucky Charms and Cookie Crisp. There is a mini golf course there, as well as an interactive exhibit on how Lucky Charms are made. Here it is shown how the leprechauns are first flayed and then pulped to be turned into marshmallows. Off to the side is a waist-high pile of abandoned little green hats that will be shipped back to Ireland under international treaty. "Am I the only one here who finds this a little creepy," I ask aloud. Elaine ignores me. "You can have your picture taken and put on a box of Wheaties," she says. "That's insane," I say. I can't be aroused by a picture of myself. Where are the Mary Lou Retton boxes?
第五天，伊莱恩带我去参加Cereal Adventure，这是一个由通用磨坊（General Mills）运营的迷你主题公园，他们是Trix、Lucky Charms和Cookie Crisp的制造商。那里有一个迷你高尔夫球场，还有一个关于Lucky Charms如何制造的互动展览。这里展示了小妖精是如何先被剥皮，然后变成纸浆，再变成棉花糖的。旁边是一堆腰部那么高的被遗弃的小绿帽，根据国际条约，它们将被运回爱尔兰。“我是这里唯一觉得这有点毛骨悚然的人吗？”我大声问。伊莱恩忽略了我。“你可以拍张照，然后把它放在Wheaties包装盒上，”她说。“这太疯狂了，”我说。我不能被自己的照片激起什么，玛丽·卢·雷顿（Mary Lou Retton）的包装盒在哪儿？
We then go to the Cereal Adventure Cafe which claims to have all of the General Mills cereals for sale. They have the monster cereals, Boo Berry, Count Chocula, Frankenberry. But I am surprised to learn that they have never even heard of Fruit Brute, which featured a werewolf. They have never even heard of Yummy Mummy, who was a mummy that was fruit flavored. I wonder if they really have any business running a cereal adventure cafe at all.
我们然后去了Cereal Adventure咖啡馆，它声称拥有通用磨坊所有的谷物在售。他们有怪物谷物，Boo Berry，Count Chocula，Frankenberry。但我很惊讶地发现他们甚至从未听说过Fruit Brute，它以狼人为主角。他们甚至从未听说过Yummy Mummy，一个水果味的木乃伊。我怀疑他们到底是否有能力经营一家谷物探险咖啡馆。
Day six, my last interview is with a Minnesota woman who has just opened a pastry shop using her grandmother's original cheesecake recipe. The shop is called Granny's Squeeze Cakes. I ask her if she's tried the deep-fried cheesecake on a stick that the Egyptians serve at The Minnesota Picnic. And she just smiles in a sort of sinister way that makes me think she knows that their days are numbered, and soon, she will be the cheesecake queen.
第六天，我的最后一次采访是关于一位明尼苏达州的女士，她用祖母的原始芝麻蛋糕食谱开了一家糕点店。店名叫Granny's Squeeze Cakes。我问她是否尝试过埃及人在明尼苏达野餐店供应的带棍油炸芝士蛋糕。她只是带着一种阴险的微笑，让我觉得她知道他们的日子不多了，很快，她将成为芝士蛋糕女王。
Day seven, by day now, I roam the halls. By night, I drink from the log flume in Camp Snoopy, the water all coppery tasting from the pennies. I purchase nearly nothing. Commerce suddenly seems the least interesting thing about the Mall of America for I have seen its greatest attraction. Like barnacles growing on a rock, somehow an actual living community has clung to this barren thing.
第七天，白天我游荡在大厅。晚上，我在史努比营的急流中喝酒，水因为硬币的原因尝起来有铜味。我几乎没买什么东西。商业突然间似乎是美国购物中心最不吸引人的事情，因为我已经看到了它最大的吸引力。就像藤壶长在岩石上，不知怎的，一个真正的活生生的社区紧紧依附在这个荒凉的东西上。
Every time I went by the Minnesota Picnic Stand, the Egyptian brothers were smiling, waving at Elaine and her fast-walking elderly cronies as they walked by, or getting some cheese curds ready for a regular, or gossiping with one of their favorite customers, an Hispanic gentleman in a puffy jacket with epaulets, who stopped working here years ago, but later told me he drove here once a week just to hang out with his old friends at the food court.
每次我路过明尼苏达野餐店时，埃及兄弟总是微笑着，向伊莱恩和她快步走过的老年伙伴招手，或者准备一些奶酪凝乳给常客，或者和他们最喜欢的顾客之一八卦，那是一个穿着带肩章的蓬松外套的拉美绅士，他几年前就不在这里工作了，但后来告诉我他每周开车来这里一次，只是为了和食品广场的老朋友聚在一起。
I check in with one of the Egyptian brothers on my way out of the Mall of America. "Did you ever discover why they are kicking us out?" he asks. "No," I say, "the mall officials are stonewalling me." "I have gone rogue," I explain. And he nods as only a sad Egyptian about to lose his deep-fried palace at the Mall of America can nod. "Perhaps this is for the best," he says. As I go, he gives me something fried on a stick, and I promise to eat it someday. But for him and for me, the Minnesota Picnic is over.
我离开美国购物中心时，顺便看了看其中一位埃及兄弟。“你发现他们为什么要赶我们走吗？”他问。“没有，”我说，“商场官员正在阻挠我。”“我已经单干了，”我解释说。他点点头，正如一个即将失去他在美国购物中心的油炸宫殿的悲伤埃及人所能点点头的那样。“也许这对大家都好，”他说。我走时，他给了我一些油炸在棍子上的东西，我承诺有朝一日会吃掉它。但对他和我来说，明尼苏达野餐结束了。
John Hodgman. A version of his story about the Mall of America appears in his book The Areas of My Expertise. The paperback edition is out this month.
约翰·霍奇曼。关于美国购物中心故事的版本出现在他的书《我的专长领域》（The Areas of My Expertise）中。平装本本月发行。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Chris Ladd, Seth Lind, Steven January, and Cathy Hoang. Special thanks today to Dan Pipski. Our website www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
嗯，我们的节目今天由萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、艾米·奥利里（Amy O'Leary）和丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）、克里斯·拉德（Chris Ladd）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、史蒂文·詹纽瑞（Steven January）和凯西·黄（Cathy Hoang）提供制作帮助。今天特别感谢丹·皮普斯基（Dan Pipski）。我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以完全免费收听我们的节目或购买CD。或者你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目和我们的档案。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助信贷）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who is constantly trying to buy me out of my contract here.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他一直在试图买断我在这一行的合同。
Why don't we just write you a check, and you can shut up and go home.
为什么我们不给你开张支票，你闭嘴回家吧。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week. Until then.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见。在那之前。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。